저희가 강남 프로젝트 당첨자 강남
빌딩 메이 프로젝트를 했는데 그
건물이 이번에 좀 거의 중공을 앞두고
있습니다 지금 이렇게 어 멋지게
신축이 완료된
[음악]
상태입니다 김준석 소장님을 모셔서 좀
이게 디자인 관련된 어 좀 얘기를
나눠보도록 하겠습니다 수님 안녕하세요
안녕하세요 일단은 저희가 외장이 좀
디자인을 좀 어떻게 했는지 좀 설명해
주시면 좋을 것 같습니다지 한번 아마
영상에도 있을 거예요 저희 필지에
대해서 간단하게 좀 소개를 해
드렸었는데 어 경사 지형이다 보니까
아래 부분이 지하 1층이에요 그래서
지하 1층이 노출되는 형식이었고
그래서 그 아래로 지하 2층 위로는
이제 지상 5층 규모로 신축을 했던
그런 케이스입니다 그리고 외관 같은
경우에는 저희가 모노 타일이라 그래서
벽돌 형태의 타일을 시공을 했는데
전면에서 봤을 때 이제 그 대지가
약간 이제 자각이 돼서 모서리가 이제
생기는데 그 부분까지 최대한 면적으로
활용하기 위해서 그 형태를 그대로 좀
따라갔어요 아 우리 필지도 주거
지역이라서 의조 사선 제한에 받기는
해요 물론 전면에 이제 도로가 있어
가지고 완화에 받긴 하지만
최상층에서는 이제 그 부분에 제한이
좀 있기 때문에 어느 정도 그 사선
제한이 이제 적용이 돼 있습니다
그렇다 보니까는 옥상을 활용하기보다는
최상층의 층고를 높이기 위해서네 다른
층에 비해 1.5배 정도 높은 층고를
최상층으로 계획을 했어요 아네 그래서
우리는 옥상이 좀 사용할 수 없는
그런 건물이긴 하지만 대신에 이제
지상 5층에 높이가 높다 높다 그래서
여기가 이제 층이고 그니까 실제로
보면은 6층짜리 건물이죠네 그렇게
보이는 거죠 예 그리고 지금 여기
앞에 좀 가려져 있는데 그 지하로
내려가는 그 성큰 공간이 좀 있어요
그래서 저또 아까 살짝 봤는데 확실히
입고 없고 좀 차이가 좀 있는 거
같아요 그니까 항상 저 부분에 대한
고민이 너무 많아요 왜냐면은 성큰을
계획을 하면은 지하층에는 당연히 이제
좋은 컨디션 확보가 가능해지기 때문에
장점이 되지만 그만큼 이제 지상에서
대면하는 전용 면적이 줄어들기
때문에네 어느 정도의 또 단점도 있죠
어떤 부분을 더 중점적으로 놓고
선택을 하느냐에 따른 차이가 될 거
같습니다 그래서이 사례 같은 경우에는
저희가 중계도 하고 그다음에 이제
설계도 하고 공사도 한 어 그런
케이스로 보시면 될 거 같습니다
추후에네 또 임대 그죠 그죠 임대도
진행할 예정이니까 혹시 관심 있으신
분 계시면 회사 대표 이메일로 메일
주시면 좋을 것 같습니다 어서 내부가
굉장히 좀 궁금한데 한번 내부로
들어가서 좀 한번 다시 살펴보도록
하겠습니다 지금 여기가 이제 성큰
진입하는 부분인데 지금이 부분이 전면
부분이 다 외부 공간이에요 실제 이제
지층의 상가는 어이 출입문을 통해서
이제 공간이 구분이 되고 지하
2층으로 진입하실 부분들은 이제이
계단을 통해서 바로 내려가게 되고
이제 좌측 부분이 주차장이 됩니다
어떻게 보면 아까 말씀드린 것처럼
여기를 하 1층의 전형 공간으로 다
쓸 수 있었는데 아 그죠네 이거를
지하 2층을 위해서 우리가 이만큼
할례를 해 준 거죠 그렇지만 지하
1층에 대한 주출입구가 도로에서 바로
인지가 되고 출입 동선이 바로
확보되기 때문에 어 그렇게 분리한
조건은 아니라고 판단을 했어요음 그죠
지하부터까지네 이게 저희가 지하층
전용면적이 25평 정도 네네 계단하고
엘리베이터 홀 쪽이 여섯 평 성큰
쪽이 한 여섯 평 정도 공용 공간으로
면적이 그렇게 잡혀 있어요 그래서 총
지하는 한 이제 40평 조금 안 되는
그 정도 면적이 확보가 됐습니다
우리가 대지 내에서 제일 많은 면적을
쓸 수 있는게 지하나 사실 그죠 그죠
어
채강이 많이 됩니다 생각보다 많이
돼서 나중에 임대할 때도 되게 유리할
거 같아요 어 그리고 요거는
스프링클러에네 간이 스프링클러를
설치를 하이 가 지하층 나중에 임대할
때 어떤 업종이든 다 받을 수 있도록
예 미리 고려를 해서 설치를 해
놨습니다 일반 음식점이나 휴기 음식점
같은 이제 다중 이용업소 같은
경우에는 지하층에 있을 경우에는 간이
스프링클러 시설이 필요해요 그렇기
때문에 추후에 이거를 시공하지 않아도
되도록 공사 단계에서 미리 반영을
했어요 지금 옥상으로 올라가는 동선이
없어요 아까 말씀드린 것처럼 우리는
옥상을 따로 계획하지 않았기 때문에
계단 이나 엘리베이터가 연결되지 않고
대신에 이제 관리를 위해서 여기 이제
점검구를 설치를 해 놨어요
아 다르죠 아 그러네요네 다른
건물들고 달라요 그래서 추후에 이제
어 점검구를 개폐하며 사다리가
자동으로 내려오고 그 사다리를 통해서
올라가서 옥상을네 아 그렇구나
올라가야 되는 그런 구조입니다 아 아
이렇게 만드는게 훨씬 낫네요 진짜네
그래서 지금 5층 같은 경우에는
층고가 한 4.8m 정도네 근데 이제
상부에 이제 단열재가 또 들어가고
하다 보니까 조금 더 내려온 감은
있는데네 아래층 보시면 확실히 이제
높이가 다르다는 걸 예 느끼실 수
있고요 그 1조 사선 제한 조금 영향
받았다 그랬잖아요 그래서 저희 벽
형태가 약간 경사져 있어요 아 여기
창도 마음에 드네요 여기네 지금 이제
우리 필치 아시겠지만 전면이 지금
도로고 그 앞에 지금 다른 건물이
없어서 사실 많이 열려 있는 그런 예
사이트인데 여기를 전체 커튼홀 해서
개방감 있게 가느냐 아니면 이렇게
창들을 좀 분할해서 디자인적으로
리듬감 있는 모습을 보여주느냐 여러
가지 방향에 대해서 논의를 많이
하다가 통일감 되게 가는 거보다는
변화를 주는 거를 더 좋겠다고 의견을
주셔서 그렇게 이제 디자인하게
됐습니다 그리고 사실 이제 이런 코너
부분들은 조금 활용하기 애매한
부분들이기 한데 어쨌든이 사무실
내에서의 탕비실이 아 예 아니면
창고나 이제 회시 같은 것들로 활용할
수 있게 최대한 면적을 확보하는
기준으로 반영이 됐어요 주거 지역내에
있으면서도 사선에 의한 후퇴 발코니가
없어요 아네 그러니까 발코니가 없는게
조금 아쉽긴 하지만 그만큼 이제 또
면적을 최대한 확보했다는 뜻이니까네
그런 차이가 좀 있습니다 화장실은
남녀 구해 놨고 여기도 창이 있고요
아 이거 저는 진짜 저기 뭐야
계단실에 무조건 창을 내야 된다는
사람 중에 한 명 있거든요 근데 진짜
이거 보시면은 엄청 크죠 이게 이꼬
고가 이거 아마 이렇게 막혀 있었으면
되게 어두웠을 거네 어둡고 답답했을
거고요 사실이 창 사이즈가 굉장히
커요 그래서 아이 창을 조금 이제 뭐
공사비 절감 차원에서라도 좀 분할을
하느냐 아니면은 좀 비싸더라도 큰
창으로 가느냐 고민을 하다가 아네
그래도 확실히 5층에서이 계단식 부분
좀 다른 지역보다 좀 높은 위치라서
예 그나마 조망도 확보가 되는
위치라서 큰 창으로 하기로
결정했습니다 여기 친구도 낫지
않네요음 4층부터는 이제
3M음네 증 거고요네 이거 냉난
반기란 이것도 많 어 얘는네 냉난
반기고 이거는 이제 전열 교환기가
그래서 환기
시스템이었어요네 그래서 원래 이제
건물의 연면적이 500mm 초과되는
건물은 기계환기 시스템을 설치했어야
되는데 네네 올해 그 서울시 관련
서울시 에너지 관련된 법규가 개정이
됐어요 그래서 앞으로는 또 설치를
하지 않아도 돼요 다른 항목으로
대체해서 점수를 받을 수가 있기
때문에이 열교 한계를 두고서는 좀
논란이 많이 있었죠 이게 뭐 그렇게
효율적이지 않다라는 형들도 있었고
어쨌든이 환기 시스템이기 때문에
소음이 발생할 수밖에 없거든요 아네
그래서 그런 부분도 좀 이슈가 있었고
그 여기는 참
시설은네 그거는
이제 적 건물이 주택 용도로 사용될
때면 시설을 설치해야 되고 그 기준은
이제 경계선에서 2m라는 기준이 있어
가지고 케이스마다 좀 다르게 적용이
됩니다 물론 기준에 해당되지 않더라도
민원이 발생하면 설치하는 경우도
있고요 그렇죠 여기가 이제 4층
거고 이제 3층 그래서 계단실 다
창의 위치나 크기는 다 다르지만
어쨌든 한 개 이상의 창대를 다
확보하고 있어요 아 여기도 이제
이라는 구조고네 그리 마감은 안
하잖아요네 그죠 지금 미장까지 해
놓은 상태고 천장은 면절이라 그래서
추가로 이제 미장 없이 기존 콘크리트
타설한 변을 보수만 한 상태고네 아
바닥은 몰타 한번 시공을
했습니다음 보통은 다 이제인
임차인들이 인테리어를 하는 경우가
많아서 제가 봤을 때 한 최소이 정도
수준 정도는 하는 거 같아요네
그러니까이 정도가 이제 기본적인
수준이라고 보시면 되고 여기서 좀 더
마감을 해 준다면 이제 천장이나 벽
같은 경우에는 페인트 도장 그 바닥
같은 경우에는 에폭시 데코 타이 정도
하시는 경우도 있고 직접 또 쓰실
목적으로 신축하는 바닥을 뭐 타일로
한다든지 석채로 한다든지 이렇게 또
추가 마감을
하세요네 그리고 여기 공용 부분은
그래도 조금 손을 보긴 해야
되더라고요네 공용 부분들은 임차인
분들이 들어오셔서 이렇게 공사하는
부분이 아니기 때문에 공사 때 이제
마감을 해 줘야 되고 이번 신축 현장
같은 경우에는 바닥을 이제 석재
네네네 석재로 마감을 했습니다음 아
그리고 여기 이렇게 또 창이 크게
있네요네 그러니까 층마다 창의
위치들이 조금씩 달라요 예 위치하고
크기들이 좀 달라서 좀 층마다 그런
이제 변화는 있는 그런 형태고 항상
좀 고민을 많이 해요 우리 일반적으로
이제 사무실 용도나 상가 용도로 쓸
때는 다 각 층마다 컨디션을 다
동일하게 구성을 해 줄 것인지
아니면은 디자인에 따라서 좀 다르게
해 줄 것인지 그런 부분들이 고민이
많이 되는데 건축주 분들하고
협의하면서 그런 과정들을 좀 맞춰
나가는 거 같습니다 개인적으로는
이렇게 층마다 조금 다른 것도 괜찮은
거 같아요 여기는 그래도 더 밝은 거
같아요 뭔가네 다른 층에 비해서 조금
더 창이 이제 많은 그런 구조라 좀
더 밝아 보일 수 있습니다 그리고
이제 전층이 아직 다 조명 설치가
되지는 않았는데 이렇게 천장에 이제
레이스 예 설치하고 이제 LED 바
조명 다 들어갈 거예요 그리고 화장실
같은 경우에는 이제 남녀 구분은
했는데네 안쪽은 저 이제 뒤쪽으로
창이 계획돼 있고 한 화장실은 이제
측면으로 예 또 창이 계획이 돼
있어요 그래서 화장실마다 또 창의
위치에 따라서 좀 그런 느낌들이
달라질 수 있습니다 그러네요네 그리고
화장실에 들가 창은 나중에 다 불투명
처리를 할
거예요네 여기가 1층이에요 그래서
아까 여기 바로 들어올 수도 있고요네
그래서 사실이 건물에 대한 주출입
봉선은 1층으로 연결이 돼요 그래서
건물 옆쪽을 통해서 이제 메인
계단으로 엘리베이터 홀로 바로 진입할
수 있게 지금 오늘 그 공사를
진행하고 계세요 그니까 이렇게
시선으로 봤을 때는 여기가 1층
높이는 아니죠 사실 2층 예 2층의
높인데 뭐 구조상 이 부분이 1층이
됩니다 뭔가 지상층 한 계층을 이득본
느낌이고요 그다음에 일조 사선이
완화되기 때문에 도로 때문에 5층도
그렇게 층고를 높게 확보가 할 수가
있었고 어떻게 보면 그 땅에 활용할
수 있는 거를 최대한 활용할 수 있는
어 그런 땅이었던 거 같습니다네
여기가 이제 여기가 이제 아까 예
보셨던 지하 1층 그래서 지하 1층은
저 도로 쪽에서 바로 입할 수 있도록
동선이 확보가 돼 있습니다 그래서
이제 나중에는요 성크 주변으로 흙을
메워 가지고 경사 형태를 그대로 따라
올라갈 거고 그다음에 계단이 있어서
이제 1층 엘리베이터 홀로 진입할 수
있는 동선이 만들어질 거예요 그리고
아까 말씀드린 것처럼 도로와 우리
돼지를 경계를 구분하기 위해서 이제
지금 가격이 시공될 거고요 나중에
이제 외관을 한번 이렇게 쭉 둘러
보시면 우리가 아까 내부에서 봤던
창들이 왜 다른 위치에 다른 크기로
구성이 돼 있는지를 예 보실 수
있으실 거예요 아 외부 마감에 대해서
이제 좀 말씀드리면 모노 타일이라
그래서 벽돌 형태의 타일로 시공을
했는데요 이렇게 모서리 부분이 생겨요
그 모서리 부분들을 처리하는 방법들이
또 몇 가지가 있는데 어
졸리컷이라고도 하고 뭐 모따기 하고
뭐 여러 가지 용어로 얘기를 하는데
그 벽돌 타이가 타일의 끝부분을
커팅을 해서 예 모서리를 맞춰서
시공하는 방법을 써 가지고 예
시공했어요 그러니까 모서리에 들어가는
벽돌들을 모두 다 커팅을 해야 되는
거예요 그렇게 해서 지금 시공이 돼
있는 상태고 수직적으로 쌓이는 벽돌
타일들은 이제 매지가 그래서 줄눈이
들어가는데 수평적으로 연속해서 붙는
벽돌 타일들은 무메지 그래서 그 줄눈
없이 따다다닥 붙게 시공을 했어요
그것도 시공 방법이 이제 조금 더
까다로운 타입이라서네 그런 식으로
해서 조금 다른 현장의 벽돌 타이들
하고는 다른 방법으로 시공이 됐습니다
아 네네네 그래서 좀 둘러봤는데 어
지금 일단 좀 전체적으로 좀 정리를
하자면 저희가 이거를 어 매입가는
이제한 50억 정도에 매입을 했어요
그다음에 이제 취득세란
공사비지수 있기로는 이제 그 중간에
시설 작금 대출도 받았거든요네
그러면서 이제 최종 현금 들어간게 한
20억 한 중반 중후반 뭐요 정도
투입돼 가지고 강남구에 50억짜리
건물을 사서 신축하지 완료한 어 그런
사례라 보시면 될 거 같습니다
그래서이 프로젝트는 거의 한 3 4년
된 거 같네 그 중간에 좀 시간이
있었 근데 이제 그때 상승장에서
매물을 좀 많이 놓치면서 좀 시간이
많이 흘렀는데 다음번에 한번이
프로젝트 청자분 모셔서 좀 어땠는지
번네 한번 좀 들어보면 좋을 거 같고
그 앞으로 나중에 이제 임대 마치거나
할 때 제가 또 소식도 좀 추가적으로
말씀 좀 드리겠습니다네 그래서 오늘
영상 여기까지 하고요 어 다음 시간에
도록 하겠습니다
[음악]
감사합니다